symbolisch wird luft gepumpt hat ein
start-up-unternehmen amsterdam seine
erfindung der öffentlichkeit präsentiert
barbara blasen barriere heißt sie und
soll helfen weltweit flüsse von plastik
müll zu befreien und sie hat einen
großen vorteil und das ist dass es keine
physikalische barriere für fische oder
für schiffe ist wir können 24 stunden 7
tage in der woche die bagger an lassen
und somit verhindern dass plastik über
flüsse und kanäle ins meer gelangt
philipp erhöhen ist ein deutscher
ingenieur und hat gemeinsam mit
niederländischen wissenschaftlern an
diesem projekt gearbeitet zwei jahre
haben sie gebraucht bis es perfekt war
ein plastikrohr mit löchern wird auf den
boden eines flusses verlegt so dass es
die schifffahrt nicht stört luft wird in
das rohr gepumpt wo durch blasen
entstehen die böden eine wand die das
plastik nicht durchlässt und erzeugen
eine strömung die den müll erst an die
wasseroberfläche treibt und dann an den
rand des flusses wo er einfach
weggeräumt werden kann
das gilt nicht nur für große stücke
sondern auch für kleine bis zu einem
millimeter
in der praxis wird der abfall dann in
solchen becken aufgefangen die grachten
reiniger von amsterdam müssen das
plastik dann nicht mehr raus fischen
sondern nur noch abholen
rudi reinigt hier schon seit 16 jahren
dass er durch die neue erfindung
arbeitslos wird fürchtet er nicht
es gibt so viel plastik in den grachten
wir haben genug zu tun
jeden tag werden 3500 kilo abfall aus
den grachten geholt darunter 115 kilo
plastik darum musste die stadt nicht
lange überredet werden das neue system
zu testen
es ist eine sehr kosteneffiziente art
und das plastik problem anzupacken
die kann andere maßnahmen aber nicht
ersetzen das problem ist so groß dass
wir verschiedene
da keinerlei gefahr für tiere bestünde
sei diese luftdruck sperre in jedem
fluss der welt zu nutzen sagen ihre
erfinder